foreign
[Music]
to the mandiant cloud security briefing
um I am
Andrew Kapinski I'm an intelligence
analyst for mandian and Google Cloud I
specifically work with people like John
Holquist like Sandra Joyce mostly to
focus on what we call Strategic
Communications for intelligence
this really kind of focuses at its
Essence on how to tell all of the cool
stories that come out kind of across
security all across across Google cloud
and delivering those cool stories to
audiences like yourself internal and
external as well as helping a lot of
people across Google Cloud tell all the
cool stories that we find
so I'm here today for a couple of
different reasons uh one we are just shy
of the one year mark of mandate
officially becoming part of Google Cloud
which means we pretty firmly have our
feet kind of on the ground we have an
understanding of uh where we kind of sit
across Google security and really most
importantly
we've gotten through the process of kind
of widening our lens and understanding
this kind of broader perspective that
Google has always had two
the last 18 months in cyber security for
those of you who've been paying
attention
really have been probably the most
dramatic shifts uh that I certainly have
ever seen in my career uh most people
who I've spoken to agree that we are in
a dramatically different place than we
were about 18 months ago pretty much
across the board which is uh interesting
to see
when I was kind of preparing for this
presentation I found a dozen really
different metrics looking at kind of 100
different aspects of really what boils
down to the same thing which is
measuring the use of cloud computing uh
and cloud in general across pretty much
all Industries and it's they all pretty
much agree uh every industry out there
continues to rise in their use of cyber
Cloud environments Cloud ecosystems
Cloud resources and this rise in Cloud
adoption really has been pretty great
for most Industries there's been kind of
an overall drop in the price of storage
the cost of computing efforts uh all the
different resources that come along with
Cloud but
this widespread adoption of cloud really
has resulted in a much wider what we
call a tax surface for malicious actors
and so what we're seeing now is this
kind of broad increase in the number of
actors targeting Cloud environments and
almost more importantly an increase in
the reasons behind those attacks the
actors that we track from all sorts of
different motivations are regularly
targeting Cloud environments and they're
doing it in increasingly brilliant ways
so what I'm here today to kind of talk
about
is who we see targeting Cloud
environments
how they're doing it and most
importantly why that matters for those
of you who are interested in Cloud
security
we're going to focus first and foremost
on what we call Initial access ttps it
means how they're getting in the very
first step in the attack chain that
attackers use when they're breaking into
some sort of cloud environments and
while we're talking about this and
really throughout this whole
presentation I want you to keep one
phrase in mind
you don't need to break in if you can
steal the keys this is really kind of
central to a lot of the tactics the
techniques the procedures that we've
seen from all of these different actors
who've been targeting Cloud for some
time so let's start with to me what is
kind of the scariest realization in
Cloud Security today so depending on the
sources you're using to gauge this
metric depending on who you ask and
where you're looking about 60 to 70
percent of the compromises that we see
as a security apparatus
inside Cloud environments begins with
credential compromise
and when some of my colleagues first
told me that my jaw kind of Hit the
Floor
but really to understand why that's so
shocking I want to put this into
perspective when I say 60 to 70 percent
of compromises begin with stolen
credentials what that means is fishing
spear fishing vulnerabilities uh supply
chain compromises any of the other
tactics that actors use to break into a
cloud environment
combined are less common in what we're
seeing than credential compromise
why
the simple fact is and I'm sure
everybody here knows this taking an
entire organization any organization and
conducting this kind of major move to a
cloud or a hybrid environment or even
using Cloud resources in ways that you
haven't used them before is really
really difficult It's Tricky it's
technically difficult it's a Personnel
nightmare depending on your organization
in many cases from this kind of personal
perspective it's never going to leave
anybody happy at the end of the day
nobody's going to say wow I had a great
day today integrating into this new
Cloud environment but
the one thing that we continue to see is
the thing that makes it easier for
people inside your organization your
engineers your sys admins your network
folks your service folks or security
folks
the thing that makes it easier for them
to do their job well and do their job
happily is breaking down who can do
their job and who has access to what
different parts of your organization
inside everything that you own based on
identity this isn't a secret identity
access management is kind of the core of
beginning cyber security inside a cloud
environment
your service accounts need to make sure
that they can fix problems based on
everybody who's using Services your
security folks want to go into any part
of your organization whether it's cloud
or hybrid or on-prem and they want to
find the bad stuff and fix it but the
truth is like I said the easiest way to
actually get a cloud or hybrid
environment to work or even just not to
break is to manage who can see what and
to use their identity as a way to
control access
unfortunately
we are not the only people who have
realized that malicious actors have
realized that as well and this isn't
just useful for Good Guys what we're
starting to see is bad guys have
realized exactly how powerful credential
access has been to the point where we
are starting to see some attacks where
actors are burning incredibly valuable
and Powerful zero days just so they can
ensure that they can get access to a
cloud environment or other environment
and get access in a way that allows them
to then steal credentials that means one
of the most powerful sophisticated tools
that an actor can bring to an attack is
being used in an end game really just to
steal credentials
this isn't the only type of compromise
that we've seen though there are plenty
of other
ways that actors can go about conducting
uh intrusions and even though there is
an easy path comparatively when it comes
to credentials that's not always the
path that we see these actors take
vulnerabilities and specifically
vulnerabilities in the software or
hardware systems that sit right at the
perimeter of a network
are also extremely dangerous for actors
who are trying to compromise a cloud
environment and in fact some of the
cases of vulnerabilities inside Cloud
environments can actually be much more
dangerous than stolen credentials for
The Wider Community I want to talk about
why
everybody in here is aware that you know
for the past several months every time
there's a big zero day that comes out
there's a huge cycle but especially this
year it might seem like you're hearing
about new zero days every other week and
we're going to dig into this a little
bit more uh in a bit
but if you go all the way back into the
distant past and think about some of the
worst vulnerabilities that have hit log
for shell for instance I know many of
you had a shiver of fear that went down
the back of your spine and hearing those
words but
the reason that log for Shell wasn't so
wasn't was particularly dangerous wasn't
because it was widespread or because it
was easy to execute the reason that it
was dangerous is because the ability to
execute log4 shell on a system that was
running log for Jay
was trivial and easily available
everybody who wanted it had access to
that script and it made it very easy for
them to use it
when we see vulnerabilities being used
at the pace at which they have been over
the past 18 months really and several
years even further we start to see the
risks really start to hit home when some
of these vulnerabilities become publicly
available
but again cloud cloud vulnerabilities
not the only thing out there that's
causing a lot of trouble
misconfiguration I'm not going to spend
too much time on this everybody knows
it's difficult to get everything working
exactly as correctly as you need it to
be
but one of the most dangerous things
about misconfiguration is that it allows
certain Acts or actors
opportunistic access on a one-off basis
based on mistakes made inside your
organization or with the ways that you
interact with other organizations very
very difficult to catch unless you know
exactly where to look and how to
identify some of these misconfigurations
but again not the most common and the
last TTP that I want to talk about is
supply chain compromise when it comes to
Software
this is a really fascinating example and
again one of the examples of initial
access that is particularly dangerous
when we talk about scale if you go back
in time and think about one of the most
dangerous software supply chain
compromises that's happened in recent
years if you go back to the solar winds
breach one of the problems with solar
winds was that the initial access of
those particular actors who we now know
to be apt-29
were able to gain initial access to
about 18 000 victims at the end they
only compromised about a handful of them
but the problem with software supply
chain compromise is that it allows
actors to gain massive amounts of access
based on one particular attack chain in
the hands of someone like a ransomware
group The solarwinds Campaign would have
been devastating and would have resulted
in a huge huge amount of compromises
that would have potentially crippled
some serious Industries
these are the kinds of threats that
we're really really concerned about when
it comes to tracking what particular
methods these actors are going to use to
gain access to a cloud environment but I
want to talk more specifically about who
we are worried about
if you know anything about mandate you
know that cyber Espionage is one of our
biggest concerns this is where we spend
a lot of our time and effort in tracking
state-sponsored groups that are
conducting cyber intrusions
they are the most dangerous generally
and most sophisticated types of actors
that we track so it's no surprise that
we've seen the most dangerous and
creative methods used to compromise
Cloud ecosystems come from exactly these
kinds of actors
and I want to reiterate that when we say
cyber Espionage actors we're talking
about actors sponsored by Nations to
achieve a huge array of different goals
understanding how these actors are tasks
what their goals are and what they need
to accomplish their mission really is
critical to understanding not just why
they might come after you but how and
therefore how to protect yourself
so let's start with the most dangerous
group of cyber Espionage actors
Far and Away the number one spot of
cyber for cyber Espionage actors in
terms of danger and sophistication comes
from Chinese sponsored groups this huge
number of intrusions that we see each
year especially in the last couple of
years especially focusing on zero days
involved an actor tied probably in many
cases to a Chinese Nexus Espionage
operation
Chinese Espionage campaigns have been
really interesting for a long time but
specifically in the past couple of years
we've started to see
the later stages of an evolution
in the distant past you would see PRC
Affiliated activity focused on social
engineering and fishing now what we're
seeing is that they're focused on
hitting what we call Edge infrastructure
like I said that stuff that sits right
between your network and the internet
we've also seen them improve a lot in
their obfuscation and their operational
security they're focused very heavily on
developing infrastructure that allows
them to conduct a lot of very dangerous
attacks
but the past few years what's really
really shown in cyber Espionage
campaigns stemming from China is that
they have been burning zero days at a
rate that is really truly staggering
so depending on the circles that you run
in on Twitter
you might have seen the phrase hot zero
day summer prop up a couple of times
that is a uh tongue-in-cheek phrase but
what we're talking about is a very very
real phenomenon this past summer has
been host to some of the most dangerous
and worrying zero days that have come up
in the past decade
we've seen a huge amount of effort by uh
mostly Chinese sponsored groups to use
these zero days in a ways that are
incredibly dangerous
in the last two years the pace of
Chinese zero-day exploitation has
accelerated very very significantly a
lot of the evidence that we've seen of
Chinese cyber Espionage actors
exploiting zero days uh was dramatic we
saw 11 different zero days being
exploited in 2021 and nine in 2022 the
number is continuing to go up this year
of those zero days that we've seen that
have been targeted and used by Chinese
Nexus Ops have been focused on flaws in
virtualization software networking
products and security devices like
firewalls vpns and email security
appliances
what is important about this is that
like I said the problem with the zero
day isn't that it's used by one group
the problem with the zero day is that it
targets a vulnerability that does not
yet have a patch and in certain
circumstances if the code used to Target
those zero days is released publicly
that is when we are really really
concerned about a growth in significant
pace and severity of attacks
these zero days that we have seen come
out from uh chinese-sponsored Espionage
groups really isn't uh it's definitely
not accidental the capability to find
and use these zero days certainly isn't
something that's happened by chance what
we're seeing like I said is the result
of years and years and years of effort
and investment by chinese-sponsored
groups to build the capability to find
and use these zero days in Rapid
succession
this is a huge infrastructure at work
that is focused almost entirely on
finding vulnerabilities and feeding them
to some of their offensive cyber
operations and specifically these
vulnerabilities are being looked for in
what we call Edge devices again the
stuff that sits right at the edge of
your network between your network and
the internet there's a couple of reasons
why that's important but hiding in the
edge primarily allows these actors to do
something that other devices on your
network don't meaning that they are
outside the normal detection radius of a
lot of cyber security capabilities if
they're hiding in something like a
router if they're hiding in something
like virtualization software the
hypervisors that guide a lot of
different VMS if they're hiding in
something like a firewall
none of these things fall within your
normal parameters for detecting
malicious activity and it allows them to
set up this campaign and sit as close as
they can inside their uh targeted
Network
the other thing we've seen in a
development from Chinese cyber Espionage
campaigns is this ability to stay
invasive out in the wild they've been
focusing on building up this kind of
massive iot botnet they're using many of
these different botnets as smoke screens
and they're using tunneling tools to try
and hide a lot of their activity making
it very very difficult to track some of
their activity in the wild and more
importantly very difficult to actually
defend against that activity once it
starts hitting your network
the other really surprising sponsor of
cyber Espionage that I think has posed a
significant threat over the past couple
of years is North Korea
they've really stepped up their game in
the past couple of years and you kind of
have to hand it to them they are really
really dramatically more dangerous than
they have been over the past several
years what we've seen is that this Focus
has come out of North Korea and cyber
Espionage that really is still doing its
classic North Korean intelligence
missions it's targeting defectors anyone
aligned against them and the
geopolitical stage they're specifically
interested in nuclear anything to do
with the Korean peninsula
but the real Innovation that's coming
out of North Korea is focused on
actually funding their ongoing cyber
Espionage campaigns and they're turning
to crypto to do it almost every dprk
actor that we track is in some way
engaged in criminal activity and it's
really focused very heavily like I said
on crypto most of it is coming out of
some of their General reconnaissance
bureaus
but they really have also learned to do
some pretty significant and Innovative
stuff one of the things that we've
learned is that when they conduct a
large-scale intrusion and steal a
significant amount of crypto
they can't then turn around and spend
that crypto immediately they have to
launder it somehow The Innovation here
is really fascinating because what
they've started doing is investing in
the means to mine more crypto which is
in effect actually laundering their
cryptocurrency they buy things like
computing power or hash power they also
buy a lot of the uh gpus that have been
on sale or server space anything like
that and use that to then mine new
crypto and use that scheme and that
output of that crypto to then fund their
continued operations sometimes literally
to keep the lights on for their offices
where they work to try and support their
Espionage campaigns fascinating
fascinating stuff coming out from North
Korea in the past couple of years and
very very dangerous especially because
we've seen them become very competent
when it comes to software supply chain
compromise
North Korea in particular has become
very very good at software as a service
targeting they've been going after this
kind of targeted supply chain compromise
we wrote A Blog about this one in
particular but there's another one that
has also happened I think in the past
couple of
several several months ago but the
ability to conduct these targeted supply
chain compromise attacks is really
really fascinating and again
a very dangerous capability for North
Korea to be displaying in their
operations
the other major sponsors of cyber
Espionage that we want to talk about
briefly are Russia first and foremost
Russia is fascinating for a lot of
different reasons but really in the past
18 months they've undergone a very
fundamental shift in how and why they do
business and subsequently a shift in who
is it going to be likely affected by
Russian cyber espionage
the answer to all of those questions is
one word it's Ukraine they're very very
interested in what's going on inside
Ukraine any of the campaigns that we've
seen that have been focused outside of
Ukraine have really focused very heavily
on diplomatic and geopolitical support
for ongoing uh Ukrainian resistance to
this invasion
although Russia's down it's very clearly
not out the Russian Gru the FSB so Apes
28 29
some of the other groups that we track
as Russian cyber Espionage campaigns
sandworm turla they're still out there
they're still very dangerous they still
have their focus very intensely set on
Ukraine but whether that continues in
the future uh is fluid and we will
continue to see how it develops moving
forward based on the outcome of this
ongoing invasion
and then the last of what we call the
big four sponsors of cyber Espionage is
Iran this one luckily has been again
very geopolitically focused uh most of
the Iranian special uh cyber Espionage
that we've seen has been focused very
heavily in their immediate region
they're very concerned with uh the back
and forth between Israel and Iran uh
there's been quite a bit of other
targeting coming out from
iranian-sponsored cyber Espionage but
it's very difficult to kind of say with
any certainty that they are determined
to move beyond their kind of immediate
Regional Focus
unfortunately we're not only concerned
about cyber Espionage when it comes to
threats to Cloud environments the big
concern that we have and I think
probably the more immediate concern to
most organizations out there is probably
coming from cyber crime actors
what's really been fascinating going
back to my original point
is that cyber crime actors especially
you've been tracking them for quite some
time
tend to follow a very specific and
darwinian set of principles
they're focused on making the maximum
amount of money for the least amount of
effort and the least amount of risk
if you've been looking at threat
activity for a while you might be
surprised to see here that a lot of the
cyber crime actors that we've been
tracking for a long time have kind of
reverted to form a lot of what they've
been doing lately has been focused very
specifically on Stolen credentials as a
means to conduct intrusions
with a rise in ransomware activity that
we saw several years ago really start to
kick off that has shifted now into
primarily an information theft game
we started to see this kind of shift
years ago in cyber criminal gangs
foregoing targeting individual bank
accounts and monetary accounts or credit
cards and really start to focus on mass
targeting organizations
what we're seeing coming out from cyber
crime actors with this focus on
conducting information theft and holding
organizations for ransom is really their
latest method in conducting what their
prime directive is which is finding
profit doing crime
the interesting thing about the past
couple of years is that we've started to
see this really rapid disruption in the
underground economy in a lot more actors
really starting to offer and look for
stolen credentials
the other thing that's happening is that
in Beyond just buying and selling stolen
credentials they are buying and selling
the means to Steel credentials if you're
familiar with kind of the underground
actors and their uh ecosystem
you know that most of what happens in
there has really become fragmented as
actors have become more specialized a
lot of them have been very very focused
on building out these specific services
that are very professional very well run
that are focused on doing one particular
thing some of them are initial access
Brokers some of them are specifically
ransomware Brokers some of them are
ransomware developers a lot of what
we've seen over the past couple of years
is that more and more actors are
expanding this kind of Underground
Market into buying and selling not only
credentials but the means to obtain them
a lot of this actually comes up to uh
what I like to think of as leading
indicators if we go back to the log for
Jay and the log for Shell incident some
of the first people who really started
to sound alarm bells in that incident
weren't big security vendors it was
people running individual Minecraft
servers because this
exploit got leaked people were scanning
for anything running Java in a
vulnerable position and then all of a
sudden their servers started dying
because it was you know being hijacked
by all these actors who were just
starting to do exactly this crypto
jacking thing in my opinion crypto
jacking probably is an indicator of
further compromise if somebody got in
with a crypto Jacker somebody's probably
else has figured out how to get into
your network
these kinds of threats though as they
develop
are
less of a concern I think than what
we're seeing right now this focus on
credentials being used to Target cloud
is not a coincidence
malicious actors understand that that is
the best way to go about not only
intruding into a cloud environment but
just running a cloud environment in
general
there are a lot of risks that are facing
everyone involved with and who uses
Cloud on a daily basis and it's very
much true that those risks are
increasing in number and sophistication
but it's important for me to state that
those risks aren't nebulous they aren't
some kind of unknowable inevitability
the key to understanding those risks the
key to comp countering those risks is
the entire purpose of cyber intelligence
it's our job to track and find and
quantify those risks and communicate
them to you so that you know what you
can do about it at the very onset of the
uh the Russian invasion of Ukraine
Sandra Joyce had a very very excellent
point which is prepare don't panic and
she was talking specifically about the
invasion but that actually comes in
handy for anyone who is concerned about
cyber security especially when it comes
to Cloud there are a lot of unknowns out
there when it comes to Cloud there are a
lot of unknowns when it comes to cyber
crime cyber Espionage all the different
malicious actors
cloud is an evolving space and the
threat actors are learning right
alongside the rest of us
they've come pretty much to the same
conclusion that we have that the best
way to understand any living given Cloud
environment is to use identity access
and see who has access to your org and
what they can do with it
and like I said at the beginning the
reason that we're seeing this focus on
credentials is because like I said it's
easier to steal the keys than it is to
break in
after nearly a year of mandate working
inside and alongside Google I can
confidently say that mandian and Google
Cloud are laser focused on doing our
absolute best to help in whatever way we
can there's nobody out there who has a
silver bullet there's no magic bean
that's going to make you unable to be
compromised
the best thing that you can do is just
your best and our job is to make sure
that you are as prepared as you possibly
can be to achieve that
I think that's all we have time for so
thank you very much appreciate it and
we'll uh talk to you again next year